[Music]
[Applause]
long time NFL reporter 26 years with the
mothership based in Dallas
and he's covering college football with
Deion Sanders over the weekend Edward
joining us on the program what happened
they didn't have enough reporters to go
see Dion's debut and you got to go
well I you know I live 40 minutes away
and you know budget's being what they
are
um and and you know they wanted to see
what kind of range I had
journalistically college football and
pro football and I I do know Dion
um and uh maybe that was the reason we
had a problem I don't know okay help me
understand here what you wrote that Dion
referred to now once again
um Marvin can we play the clip where
Ed's being singled out by Dion Sanders
you you
will hold on hold on oh no do you
believe in that huh oh no no no I ran
through that bull junkie wrote that I
ran through that I sipped it through all
that yeah oh no come on do you believe
you don't believe
you just answered it you don't believe
next question all righty what was the
bull junk that you wrote Ed
well well first of all
you know in the moment it just did not
seem journalistically approached in that
situation for me to meet his demand and
tell him that I believed it and whether
I do or I don't uh and and interacting
with him as I mentioned you know over
the years he played for the Cowboys
played a long time in the NFL as a Hall
of Fame player and interacting as often
as we have I can't imagine that he
really expected that I was going to
commit to either position in that
circumstance because it was
unprofessional to do so
uh fortunately he realized it wasn't
going to happen and eventually he moved
on without taking my question because if
he was intent on waiting we'd still be
there but I don't really understand why
did it matter
um you know in that moment after all he
and his sons and his coaching staff and
his players had accomplished
why
so for me to dismiss my obligations to
be fair and objective and commit to Dion
so that he would entertain my question
um as for your question I I really don't
know I haven't been a writer in 30 years
I don't cover college football this was
an exception
um I asked him as you heard multiple
times what did I write and he couldn't
ever provide an example and the reason
is no such example exists uh I've been
doing television for the last 30 years
I'm almost exclusively a TV reporter and
as you know uh now I am active on social
media and some people have pointed to a
Twitter post I had in March in which I
said this exactly Colorado celebrity
football coach has made CU Buffs
football the most interesting program in
the country it's number two in
merchandise sales Folsom Field Suites
are sold out and season ticket renewal
rate stands at 97 percent Deion Sanders
has created attention before his first
win
how did it how does that somehow make me
a doubter
but but he's using you as you were a
prop
it didn't matter who was there for ESPN
they would have been a prop you're the
face of ESPN and he's calling out ESPN
he's calling out a group and you just
happen to be the person who was there
representing ESPN that would be my my
take on this he didn't want to hear what
was fact he was performing
true you know and I think one of the
things sadly that's happened in in the
media business now and I think it plays
into this type of reaction is
you can almost argue there are more
there are more former athletes in the
media now than actual professional
reporters and so these players have a
tendency I think to praise one another
uh whether deserved or not and so that
leads in a situation like this if he's
referring to my tweet where somebody
sees something
um that's not overwhelmingly positive
and instead it feels negative in the
context that they're used to I mean if
that tweet is what came off and maybe
you're right maybe maybe it was more who
I was working for although as I
mentioned you know I've covered Dion for
a long time and we've had a complicated
history we've had moments where we got
along great and he helped me do my job
and consented to sit-down interviews and
we've had moments where it wasn't so
wonderful and and during the Terrell
Owens situation he he asked as a
commentator for NFL Network at the time
why couldn't I be the one who was lying
instead of to being the one who was
lying so I don't know if you're right I
think it's entirely possible I also
think it is possible that he was overly
sensitive to this tweet where I refer to
him as a celebrity coach although I
don't know how he doesn't think he's a
celebrity he would be offended if you
told him he was not a celebrity wouldn't
he
[Laughter]
I wouldn't take it personally I don't
know if you are even though he made it
personal to me I mean I've had a million
things worse happened to me after a
press conference or in a professional
situation where I'm reporting on
something I've been you know I've had
players threaten to kill have me killed
not do it themselves of course they
contracted out uh wait wait wait wait
wait wait hold on hold on hold on what
what happened where a player said I'll
have you killed or in so many words
well I referenced the uh Tara lowen
situation I reported uh at ESPN that
Terrell Owens had become a toxic
influence in the Cowboys locker room uh
and that they were going to consider
after the season releasing him even
though they would have to take a 10
million dollar cap hit and he was
undeniably one of their best offensive
players
um but it had become an issue with
certain players including Tony Romo and
Jason Witten and some members of the
coaching staff and I reported that and
the next day I went out to the locker
room because that's what you do when
you're a real reporter is you go out and
see if anybody wants to take issue with
you uh Tio would not talk to me before I
published the story and he didn't want
to talk to me then but other players
were highly upset and tank Johnson being
one of them threatened to kill me and
said he was going to send some people to
my house and he asked me Dan he asked me
where do you live and I said tank if
you're going to kill me I'm not going to
make it that easy like you're going to
have to do a little work here
okay and so do you know he had seen his
bodyguard killed in front of him not
long before he had he had done jail time
for weapons offenses and having you know
dog fighting and all this other stuff so
he was entirely capable of my opinion
it's the only time of my life Dan I ever
got a gun to defend myself I didn't ever
need to use it but and tank and I got
along fine after that but I took him
seriously in the moment did you call
police security like I mean no I didn't
just like this I didn't want to make a
big deal out of it I went I didn't tell
the Cowboys PR people I didn't go to the
league I went to their security person
quietly and said hey just so you know
and if there's anything you can do to
defuse the situation in case he's
serious
you know here's what happened and we
they took care of it quietly if they did
anything he never did anything as far as
I know and then a few months a few years
later I called the league office for
somebody said you know tank works in the
league office down right down the
hallway from Roger yeah
head of security there for the
commissioner
wow we're not interested in all the just
debates and discussions that they had
about discipline and and tried to help
him out we're talking to uh Thug Life
Edward joining us on the program uh
he'll be uh covering the Kansas City
Chiefs and the Detroit Lions back to his
regular job the Lions there on Thursday
night
um with the Chris Jones situation
how possibility of he could actually be
back in Camp any chance he could play in
this game
you know it doesn't seem like it from
from the people I've talked to on Andy
Reid's staff since I got to Kansas City
it seems like they're prepared to play
without him as as they should be at this
point I mean almost 48 hours from the
game he hasn't been with the team in any
capacity this off season so it'd be hard
to imagine as great as he is that he
could come in and play a significant
number of snaps I mean maybe I don't
know but I don't think they they're
close to resolving the contract
situation that would lead to that
outcome anyway so I think expecting a
little is going to happen figure out
another way to take on the Lions offense
I hope the Lions keep this close
um because I don't want this to be oh
you know everybody's all in on the Lions
and then you know the fact that the NFL
said I mean the NFL has to believe in
the Lions being good right to to have
that as the opening night
um are you a believer in the Lions being
a legitimate I'm not going to say
playoff team more than a playoff team
this year
well I think with you know the state of
the Packers being what they are and
given how the Lions played at the end of
last season they won what eight of their
last 10 games uh I think they were fifth
or sixth in the league and offense and
scoring so they have that capacity to
put points on the board and win games I
think Jared Goff this will be a great
format for him an opportunity you know
he threw 29 touchdown passes last year
but only six came on the road
um and so he's got to be better more
consistent than that if the Lions are
Going to fulfill what they think are are
attainable goals this season but yeah I
think the Lions can play I think the
interesting part of this you know
without without Chris Jones that
obviously makes it more important for
the Chiefs to be able to score and and a
lot of people are questioning again well
they lost you know some receivers and
Nicole Hardiman and uh Schuster Smith
but you know Patrick Mahomes was the
rare quarterback who prevailed in that
situation last year he lost Tyree kill
and where Aaron Rodgers struggled
without Devonta Adams and Dak Prescott
led the league in interceptions without
Amari Cooper and Ryan Tannehill had a
miserable season without AJ Brown you
know he lost Tyree kill arguably the
best of all those receivers and went out
and still led the league in scoring and
total offense and won another Super Bowl
so he's proven that he's able to
overcome a lot of adversity that maybe
other quarterbacks can't
why will this year be different for the
Cowboys
I don't know what you mean by that
they've won 12 games two years in a row
how about the postseason Why will why
will the postseason be different for the
Cowboys
I don't know if it will be no
um you know I think there are a really
talented team I spent a week with him at
training camp uh this is one of the most
talented teams I think the Cowboys have
ever had Dak Prescott's pretty much had
good teams every year you know as Troy
Aikman said I think the thing they
haven't done for a long time is they
haven't played their best football
against the best opponents in the
postseason
um and and certainly the 49ers are you
know uh an ominous uh opponent because
of how well they play defense and they
shut the Cowboys down two years in a row
in the playoffs and eliminate them and I
think that's why Mike McCarthy's calling
the play is now and I think Mike feels
really that he can really make a
contribution in that way and I think he
and Dak have a great relationship and if
uh you know I I don't think Dak Prescott
I mentioned he led the league in
interceptions I think that's the
aberration I don't think he had an
interception problem man I think he had
a wide receiver problem and I think it's
a wide receiver problem they've taken
care of with the acquisition of Brandon
Cooks
your Super Bowl pick is what
uh my Super Bowl pick is uh I picked the
Eagles and the bills with the bills
prevailing oh
are you covering any more of Deion
Sanders games this season
not that I know of I uh nobody from
Bristol has called and asked if I'm
available to go to Boulder and cover the
Cornhuskers this week you should just
show up you know just no credential just
show up just go into the press
conference there and let him call you on
that question no I've had a question for
a week that I like that
I don't know yeah uh Dion you didn't
answer this question from last week I
showed up to see if you'd answer it uh
this week uh yeah I know you're keeping
receipts Ed I'm glad you're alive I'm
glad you're you know able to cover the
uh games and uh didn't get hurt in the
process of any of this so uh we're all
grateful for that
well thanks for having me on Dan good to
talk to you as always that's Ed werder
edwarder has more ESPN NFL reporter
based in Dallas 26 years with the
mothership and he'll be covering the
Thursday night NFL opener the Lions and
the Chiefs